des images de trois rivières cet après
midi une cérémonie émouvante près de
1500 personnes ont assisté aux
funérailles communes des trois jeunes
assassinés la semaine dernière je vous
le rappelle deux adolescents sont
accusés de meurtre prémédité et de
complot dans ce drame marie claude
julien
3 corbillard trois victimes mais un seul
et même deuil
plus de 1500 personnes étaient entassées
en la cathédrale de trois-rivières pour
dire un dernier adieu aux victimes du
triple meurtre de trois rivières ouest
une célébration touchante que la famille
a voulu à l'abri des caméras mais ce
texte n'a beau comme les gens qu'on a
perdu aujourd'hui c'est vraiment toute
beauté
c'est magnifique c'était beau de voir
tout le monde se déplacer parce que
c'est déjà un vrai mac sentiment qu'on a
perdu des êtres chers ne vont que le
monde ceci implique on est loin pour
l'autre parmi les personnalités
présentes le sénateur pierre hugues
boisvenu qui n'avait pas annoncé sa
présence et qui était visiblement
bouleversée par les événements
parce que j'ai pour ce travers le même
genre de données et que je crois pas
très bien ce que la famille vie et je
pense que là d'un solidarité l'appui
déjà les qualités essentielles
il souhaite aux familles de retrouver un
sens à leur vie malgré la souffrance que
je retiens c'est toute la famille donne
un sens au passage de ces enfants dans
leur vie et de le chercher de la force
d'un parce que les mois à venir vont
être aussi pénible que les événements
comme tel la cérémonie célébrée par
l'abbé françois doucet de la paroisse
point du lac se voulait rassembleuse
dans l'épreuve
peu importe les convictions de tous et
chacun pourvu qu'on dort dans la
cathédrale
ce n'est pas juste des plats oui c'était
là mais que ce soit les hommages avec
ont raconté les belles choses que ce
soit
l'homélie ou ce soit des liens que je
fais par des belles réflexions qui
parlait des trois jeunes c'est que la
tragédie touche toute la population de
trois-rivières des centaines de
personnes qui ne connaissaient pas les
familles ont tenu à se déplacer
le to cape d en faire trop mal que ça
des choses comme ça arrivent le
continent perdu en même temps l'eau
c'est pour ce prix du tableau les
funérailles étant maintenant terminée
les familles pourront vivre leur deuil
en toute intimité ici marie claude
julien radio canada trois rivières